Transcriber: Zeinab Alnayal
المدقّق: Eman Salah El-Din
الشركة التي بدأناها تقوم بتصنيع شيء يسمى
"الوقود الحيوي" من زيت الطعام المستخدم،
حيث نأخذ زيت الطعام المستخدم الموجود في
بيوتنا ونحوله لما يُسمَّى بالوقود الحيوي،
وهو وقود يقوم بتشغيل
الآلات والسيارات.
عندما نخبر أحداً بهذا الأمر، يعتقد أننا
نكذب أو أن المشروع ليس بالأمر الهين.
نحن مصنع أُسِّس منذ أقل من عامين،
وأنا أود أن أحكي لكم ثلاث قصص ساعدتنا
للوصول إلى شيء كهذا.
في البداية، كنا نملك بعض المال،
وأول خطوة نحتاج إلى اتخاذها هي
أن نصنع نموذجًا أوليًا يشبه مصنعًا صغيرًا
بضعف حجم هذه السجادة مثلًا
لكي نختبر به نظرية تحويل زيت الطعام
المستخدم إلى الوقود الحيوي.
كمهندسين حديثي التخرج، من المفترض أن
نتمكن من عمل هذا النموذج بسهولة.
بدأنا في التصميم لفترة وقمنا بالرسم
وتصنيع المكونات وتركيبها ولكن..
نظريًا يبدو الأمر سهلًا ولكن
على أرض الواقع كان الأمر مختلفًا.
مبدأيًا، هناك جهاز اسمه "الخلاط"
وهو يمزج المكونات مع بعضها البعض.
كان الخلاط قوياً جداً بالنسبة للمحرك،
فقمنا بتشغيل الخلاط داخل الخزان،
وكان هناك زيت في الخزان، وكنا في فصل
الشتاء مما أدى إلى تجمد الزيت.
فقررنا إذابة الزيت المتجمد بالخزان،
فقمنا بتشغيل السخانات
فانفجر الخزان.
قمنا بإعادة التجربة فانفجر الخزان مجددًا.
أصابنا اليأس ولم ندرِ ما يجب علينا فعله.
في هذه الحالة، عادةً ما يتم استشارة
المختصين من أفراد أو شركات
متخصصين في عمل النماذج الأوَّلية.
ولكن هذا الأمر مكلف جدًا ولم يكن
باستطاعتنا تحمل ذلك.
فقررنا زيارة أحد الفنيين
في الكلية التي كنت أدرس بها،
فهو فني معمل، وقررنا طرح الموضوع عليه.
ولن نخسر شيئًا بأي حال،
ففي النهاية نموذجنا الأوَّلي لا يعمل.
فتواصلنا مع الفني واسمه سامر، وفي أقل من
يومين نجح في تركيب النموذج الأوَّلي،
واستطعنا من خلال هذا النموذج تحويل
زيت الطعام المستخدم إلى وقود حيوي.
قمنا بالتوسع قليلًا، حيث غادرنا المكان
الذي بدأنا فيه،
وانتقلنا إلى ورشة في منطقة المعادي،
وكان سامر لا يزال يعمل معنا.
بدأ مشروعنا بالنمو، وأردنا البدء
في خطوات البيع والتصدير.
أول خطوة يجب اتخاذها هو تحويل هذا النموذج
الأوَّلي الصغير إلى آلات كبيرة،
أي نبني مصنعًا.
وأول خطوة في بناء المصنع هو
تصميم هذا المصنع قبل تنفيذه.
كان هذا الأمر صعبًا بالنسبة لنا
حتى وإن كنا مهندسين،
فهناك شركات متخصصة في ذلك،
حيث تصمم مثل هذه المصانع
في مقابل مبالغ مالية كبيرة جدًا،
ولكننا كنا مستعدين للقيام بذلك.
قمنا بزيارة هذه الشركات وشرحنا لهم
ما نود القيام به،
لكننا لم ننجح في ذلك،
حيث رفضتنا ثلاث شركات.
لم نملك خيارًا آخر، إذ لابد
من تصميم المصنع.
من الذي يعمل داخل تلك الشركات؟
المهندسون الكيميائيون
فقمنا بالبحث عنهم إلى أن وصلنا
إلى أحد المهندسين
الذين يعملون في مثل تلك الشركات.
عرضنا عليه المشروع وكان متحمسًا جدًا
وقام بتنفيذ التصميم تمامًا كما أردناه،
وحصلنا منه على تصاميم جاهزة للتنفيذ.
بالتالي أصبحت التصاميم جاهزة،
لنقم ببناء المصنع.
كان سامر الفني الذي تكلمنا عنه
لا يزال يعمل معنا
فقررنا بناء المصنع سويًا.
وصل سامر في هذه المرحلة
إلى أقصى حد من خبرته،
فلم يكن قادرًا على بناء المصنع كما نريد.
افترضنا أن المشكلة في المجهود، فاستعنَّا
بالبواب الذي أمضى وقته في شرب الشاي
ولم نستفد شيئًا.
اكتشفنا لاحقًا أن مكاتب المقاولين
هي من تقوم بهذه الخطوة،
حيث يأخذون التصاميم التي نريدها
ويقومون بتنفيذها.
لكن، كما رفضتنا شركات التصميم،
فهؤلاء المقاولين، بحجة خبرتهم الكبيرة،
يبدأون بتنفيذ أمور قد لا نحتاجها أساسًا
ولا نستطيع الاعتراض على ذلك
بسبب العقد الذي التزمنا به.
كُنَّا في شهر تشرين الأول،
وحاولنا إيجاد حلول،
فقمنا بزيارة مكاتب مقاولين الحريق.
وهذه المكاتب ليست
متخصصة في بناء المصانع،
ولكنهم يعملون على أشياء تشبه
ما نقوم به وهو تركيب المواسير.
عرضنا عليهم الموضوع وقدمنا لهم
التصاميم التي نريد تنفيذها،
فوعدونا بإرسال اثنين من الفنيين
لتقديم المساعدة.
وهنا يأتي دور العم أحمد ذو ال55 عامًا،
وهو أكبر من سامر بكثير،
وقد يبدو أن المجهود الذي يقدمه
أقل كثيرًا من سامر،
ولكن في خلال 3 أيام انتهى تركيب المصنع،
فأصبح العم أحمد مساعداً لمدير
المصنع ويعمل في الإنتاج والجودة والصيانة.
اليوم، بعد أقل من 3 سنوات، تنتج
شركتنا 4 أطنان من الوقود الحيوي يوميًا.
لم نكن لنصل إلى هذا المستوى
لولا سامر والمهندس والعم أحمد،
ولو كنا ذهبنا للاستشاريين
لتصميم النموذج الأوَّلي،
أو لاحقنا شركات التصميم
التي لم ترغب في العمل معنا،
أو ذهبنا للمقاولين الذين كانوا
سينفذون أمورًا لا نريدها،
لم أكن لأقف أمامكم اليوم لأخبركم
عن مصنعنا الذي يقوم بالإنتاج بالفعل.
أنت لست بحاجة لكل الأدوات،
ولست بحاجة لكل رأس المال،
ولا حتى خط الإنتاج من الخارج،
ولا ذلك المكتب في منطقة الزمالك.
أنت بحاجة إلى الأداة التي تناسبك.
الشيء المشترك ضمن القصص الثلاثة
التي أخبرتكم بها هو
أننا حاولنا أن نرى المشكلة على حقيقتها،
فاستطعنا الوصول إلى حل كل مشكلة في كل قصة.
ما نقوم بفعله دائمًا هو أننا عندما
نواجه مشكلة معقدة
نتصور أن حلها لابد أن يكون معقدًا جدًا.
أو أنه لا يوجد حل أصلًا،
أي أنها مشكلة بلا حل.
ما نحتاج القيام به عندما تواجهنا مشكلة،
هو تفكيكها لاكتشاف المشكلة الحقيقية.
كي نتوصل للحل الحقيقي.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)